hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate
how to withdraw medication from a vial
when withdrawing a medication from a
vial you want to make sure that you're
following your employer's
latest guidelines and the drug
manufacturer's recommendations
for withdrawing that medication from a
vial
first what you want to do is gather your
supplies so you want to look at your
physician's order
and see what medications ordered then
get the correct medication in its vial
you'll also want to grab some alcohol
prep
a syringe and the size of syringe that
you get depends on how much medication
you're giving
so we're giving two mls of medication so
we grabbed a 3ml
syringe you also need a vial access
device that's going to attach to the
syringe's needle adapter to actually
help you withdraw the medication from
the vial
and there's various things you can use
to help you withdraw the medication
which we'll go over here in a second
and then you're going to need an extra
needle to actually administer the
medication because you're not going to
use the original
access device that you attached to the
syringe that helped you draw up the
medication
then you want to perform hand hygiene
after you've done that you want to
set up the syringe and attach the vial
access device
to the needles adapter if needed because
some may already be prepared
now you can use different vial access
devices to withdraw the medication from
the vial one type of device is just a
plain
needle with that beveled tip another
type is a blunt
tip fill needle and this can be used to
decrease
needle sticks during medication prep or
a filter
needle can be used now whenever you're
withdrawing medication from a glass
ampoule you'll always want to use a
filter
straw and i actually have a video that
you can check out where i demonstrate
how to do this
but some medications that need to be
reconstituted from their powder form and
removed from a vial may need this
but you want to check with your
facilities protocols and the drug
manufacturer
if a filter needle is needed to withdraw
the medication from the vial
so we're going to attach a regular
needle to the syringe's needle adapter
first what i'm going to do is i'm going
to open up this packaging
of the needle and i'm going to leave it
in there
then i'm going to open up the packaging
of the syringe
and one thing about the syringe that you
want to remember is that
you only want to touch the plunger
phalange and the barrel
you never want to touch the shaft of the
plunger
or the end of this tip because you can
contaminate your syringe
so we're going to take it out and i'm
going to hold it at the barrel
and then we're going to attach this on
here
so we're just going to open this up
and we're going to put our adapter into
the end
of the needle and what we're going to do
this is very important
you want to twist it and make sure it's
on there
very securely because if not while
you're withdrawing the medication or
going to administer it it
can easily become loose and then you're
going to have to start all over
and after you have done that you want to
keep it in its packaging
with its cap on and just set it aside
while you start to prep your vial
next prepare the vial for medication
withdrawal so you first want to
flip off the top of the vial if it's
present
like this then open an alcohol prep pad
and i'm going to clean the exposed top
of the vial
for 30 seconds and i'm going to scrub it
because this is just going to help
decrease any contamination
and then after doing this for 30 seconds
you're going to let it completely dry
now while that is drying we're going to
take our syringe and we're going to
instill
air in the syringe because we're going
to take that air and actually inject it
into this vial
prior to removing the medication now why
do we want to do that
well we want to prevent a vacuum from
forming inside
this vial so for example if not enough
air
is injected in this vial prior to
removing the medication
it will actually cause it to be very
difficult to remove the medication from
the
vial and this is especially true for
those multi-dose
vials so you may be wondering how much
air
am i going to inject in this vial prior
to removing the medication
well you're going to inject the same
amount of air that is equal to the
amount of medication
that you're going to remove from the
vial so our order says to give 2 mls of
medication so we're going to put 2 ml of
air in here
and we're going to inject 2 mls into the
vial and then we're going to remove
two ml's of medication therefore to do
this we're going to hold our syringe at
its barrel
and then we're going to remove the cap
and it's packaging in one smooth
motion and we're going to keep the cap
inside the packaging and just put this
in a secure location for when we need it
later
and we're ready to instill the air so
we're going to carefully
pull on this flange of the plunger
we're going to pull it back so you'll be
pulling it down
and you're looking at the markings on
the syringe so we're giving two ml's
of medication so we're going to pull
back at the two
mark and you want to make sure that
those
plunger seal lines lines up with that
too and here we have two ml's of air
now to inject air into the vial i'm
going to hold the vial
steady on a flat surface with my
non-dominant hand
and then i'm going to take my dominant
hand and hold the syringe
at its barrel now whenever you're using
a needle to pierce the top of a rubber
stopper
you want to use a technique that
prevents coring
so what is coring well chlorine occurs
when parts of this rubber stopper
enters into the vial and contaminates
the vial and possibly some of that
rubber stopper could be injected to the
patient and we want to absolutely
prevent this
so you can use a certain technique to
hopefully prevent that
now look at your vial most vial stoppers
have this bullseye type design
and we want to go in the center of the
bullseye
so to do that i'm going to position the
needle
at the center of the bullseye at a 45
degree
angle with the bevel of the needle
up so it's facing me and i'm going to
apply pressure
to the tip and as the needle begins to
penetrate the stopper
i'm going to push down while
simultaneously rotating
the needle to a 90 degree angle in one
smooth
motion then i'm going to inject the air
into the air space
of the vial once the air has been
injected into the vial keep the needle
access device
in the vial and then invert the vial by
using the same hand positions
with your non-dominant hand holding the
vial
and your dominant hand holding the
syringe barrel
once in position move your fingers down
to the plunger flange and we're going to
pull back
until we remove two milliliters
of medication so we're looking at
the barrel markings to the two
and we're taking care not to touch the
shaft of the plunger just the plunger
flange
and we're pulling down to two and we're
right
at two now you wanna check for any air
bubbles if you
see any lightly flick
the barrel to remove any air bubbles and
if you have any present
you want to push them out into the air
space
and then check again and make sure
you're at the two mark and confirm that
you have the appropriate amount of
medication
then you want to remove the needle from
the vial
and now we're going to remove the needle
that we use to withdraw the medication
from the vial
and apply a new needle to actually
administer the medication
and this would be the same case for if
we use a filter needle
or one of those blunt tip fill needles
you would always
change that out now why do we want to
change this needle out why wouldn't we
use it
to give it to the patient well there's
two reasons one reason is whenever we
penetrated the stopper of that vial
it can dull that needle and that would
not feel very good to the patient to get
a dull needle
if they're getting an injection let's
say also
this needle has been inside the
medication vial so
on the needle you can have some
residue of the medication and if we go
and just inject that into our patient
it can get into the surrounding tissues
and cause issues
so those are just some of the reasons we
want to do that i'm going to connect
to my new needle so it's in the
packaging
and i'm simply just going to connect it
and again the important thing you need
to do i'm going to twist it on
securely and it has its cap on
and it's ready to give to our patient so
i'm going to perform hand hygiene
double check everything again and then
i'm going to
administer the medication okay so that
wraps up this video on how to withdraw a
medication from a vial
and if you'd like to watch some more
videos on how to do some other nursing
skills you can access the link in the
youtube description below